in here in the in the middle on the
right robert littell BSO in game one you
talked about how he was going to take
personal responsibility on see outcome
to make sure that he didn't kind of blow
up like he did in game 1
can you talk about the job that you did
on them tonight and how you was able to
slow him down I mean just try to be more
aggressive you know I wanted to set a
tone on him and you know now let him get
into rhythm early and saying that you
know I didn't box-and-one him you know
and chase him around the floor like like
Richard Sherman does some guys like you
know that's a complete team effort you
know I try to do my job when I was on
him and everybody else stepped in and
did their job as well I think you know
getting back in transition was huge but
you know overall we we threw there
several different bodies Adam so I can
just come up here and be like yeah I
took him out the game like that's that's
garbage that was a complete team effort
rosh over here and left a rapid aim with
sports and dream on over here steps
scored 12 points in the last four
minutes to the half you guys get it
within five at the break then you go on
that terror how what happened in that
sequence of time in that five minutes
before and five minutes after the half
that allowed you guys to take over oh we
got stops we took away their transition
buckets and we got transition buckets so
you know we always say we're at our best
when we're getting that's our best
offense and we're getting stops and
we're pushing the ball obviously Steph
was great you know I closing out that
half for us and you know I think we
should have been down by a lot more than
five points but when you're going in you
know into the half down five we know we
can cover that in ten seconds you know
so you know arm us that was a great
coming out to half and you know DeMarcus
was big got to start the half and and
everybody was just moving without the
ball and you know we pushed the ball in
transition it was big for us standing in
the back right
draymond and Devon from the ringer
picking up on that point on DeMarcus I'm
wondering you know when you found out he
was gonna be starting tonight you know
what were you thinking about how that
might change the way you guys were able
to move on offense and then what did you
see from him as the game progressed it
seemed like he sort of got you know God
ridden to rhythm got going as the game
went along he
you know that's once once again you know
DeMarcus doesn't play much basketball
over the course the last 18 months you
know sort of more he plays the better
field he gets you know tonight he was
huge for us
no coach you know putting him in a star
lineup I think was big you know
obviously they want to attack him on a
defensive end but you watched the film
he didn't give up much on a defensive
end in Game one and similar to tonight
he was great on both ends as well so you
know and allowed us to play through him
some in the post you know they gotta
honor that or you know we know what he's
capable of if they don't right here in
the front dream on mark Schwartz ESPN
Steph after the game said it was
disrespectful of the Raptors to leave
Andre wide open for that shot given his
his pedigree what did you think of that
last possession the way Andre shot the
ball with that much time left on the
clock and the fact that Raptors didn't
get a foul oh well I didn't think they
were going to file you know they they
were trying to get a steal
I never tribal Steph Steph I left at the
bottom me they came with a trap you know
but I think as big as Andre shot was you
know we've come to expect I'm afraid to
hit big shot so you know since he's been
here and I've seen him hit several game
winners I've seen him you know put the
icing on the cake of several wins but
the way Shaun Livingston met that pass I
think you know no one will write about
that you know we all we all got a joke
amongst us of bad receivers and good
receivers I always call Kevin a bad
receiver I always call Shawn a bad
receiver he turned into Mecca Shawn
tonight for that fast it was big for us
okay next question
dream on Tennyson Maggie Eagle News
Philippines what would be the Warriors
next game plan to avoid some of the
mistakes that were made on defense and
offense I mean you always want to make
mistakes that's just the nature of the
game we play your
against you know a great team there an
NBA founders for a reason they're gonna
force you to make some mistakes but it's
about the effort that you put out there
on the floor to overcome those mistakes
and you know I think we did that tonight
you're never going to play a mistake for
a game you know none of us are expecting
that but you try to minimize the
mistakes and take advantage of you know
the opposite team mistakes Dan on your
right opposing team mistakes that was
bad Dan Feldman NBC Sports you took a
lot of personal responsibility after
game one and I think we could see early
in the game you stepping up yeah near
halftime you guys are still downtown
what's going through your mind at that
point we've grown father huh I said near
heft oh yeah you know when they got to
ten what's going through your mind at
that point are you trying to do even
more do you just figure if you keep this
up it'll it'll turn around I thought if
we kept it up we would turn around
because you know when they went on their
run I think they went up 12 we we had
three or four possessions where we got
great shots and we just missed them you
know I have you no faith in our team
there were if we continue to get you
know we always talk about just getting
this shot every time we're good enough
to where if we get a shot every time
we're going to give ourselves a chance
to win so you know we want to turn the
ball over we just getting the shot soon
and you live with those results you know
obviously we got a you know good
swinging there to close out the half and
you know the third quarter you know we
really dominated our quarter in a game
like this where you have so many
opportunities to garden so many
different types of players how much do
you enjoy that challenge I enjoy it a
lot um you know from you know Garden
Kauai is different in Garden Pascal and
Garden Pascal is different in God and
Kyle Lowry but you know as a defender as
a competitor I relish those
opportunities I have to make an impact
on the game on the defense side of
basketball you know I understand how
important that side of the basketball is
and you know no matter who I'm on I try
to you know make sure I have a big
impact on that side
thank you dream